now let's turn to the Washington swamp
where Joe Biden had a very big day after
another long weekend away from the White
House he returned to conduct a very
important meeting with the Easter Bunny
and it went well about as well as you
can imagine in just a moment we're going
to show you all of today's very sad low
lights yet predictable but first we
begin with a message to the White House
Press Secretary and soon to be msdnc
employee jensaki now last week during a
public event with her far left friends
well jensaki smeared our very own peter
Ducey and this network listen to this
we have to talk about Peter Ducey for
one second sure is he
a stupid son of a [ __ ] or
does he play a stupid son of a [ __ ] on
TV he works for a network
okay that
um provides people with questions that
nothing personal to any individual
including Peter Ducey but might make
anyone sound like a stupid son of a
[ __ ]
now I wonder if that means it's open
season now the the woke crowd is put
their seal of approval on calling people
a stupid son of a [ __ ] well I mean
hmm oh I can start with a pretty big
list myself but not only what gen sake
is doing by trashing Peter Ducey she's
also lying as per usual Peter's
questions are his own he is respectful
in how he asks the questions he asks
very good timely questions surrounding
important topics like the crisis at our
Southern border the crisis in
Afghanistan the inflation crisis the oil
and gas crisis the coven crisis the
covet hypocrisy and every other crisis
this Administration pretty much mangles
every single day so let's face it the
Biden White House as a train wreck and
they hate being held accountable by Fox
News well too bad we're here get used to
it
[Applause]
[Music]
that's a great asset more inflation
what a stupid son of a [ __ ]
what a stupid son of a [ __ ] I guess
that in woke land means it's okay to
call the say that to about anybody you
care to say it about wasn't that long
ago when Biden vowed to bring kindness
respect Unity back to the White House
and he said that if he acted this way
he'd be fired on the spot no ifs no ands
no buts he said it take a look
I'm not joking when I say this
if you're ever working with me and I
hear you treat another colleague with
disrespect
talk down to someone I promise you I
will fire you on the spot
on the spot
no if fans or butts
everybody
is entitled to be treated with decency
and dignity
Joe has to fire himself right on the
spot no ifs Sands or buts and he has to
fire Jen sake what happened Joey now of
course sake will not be fired and to
borrow a phrase at this point well what
difference does it make sake already has
one put out the door and keep in mind
instead of getting critical information
to you the American people we the
American people saki spent the last 14
months auditioning for her new gig at
msdnc full of so-called clap backs as
they call them and other made for TV
moments so congratulations to Jen saki
according to reports she got the job
she's going to fit right in there
because for the most part maybe a few
exceptions her new colleagues are holier
than thou conspiracy theorists and
totally completely dishonest partisan
hacks that pretend to be journalists so
Jen I guess you'll feel right at home
and you can keep on lying and you'll
probably get paid a hell of a lot more
than you're getting paid now after all
she was a big supporter of the Russia
collusion hoax we know that she even
strongly suggested Hunter Biden's laptop
Scandal was Russian disinformation we
now know that's not true saki was lying
but she still refuses to correct the
record we know Jen saki also lied about
Afghanistan she said quote it's
irresponsible to say that Americans are
stranded they are not well they were and
of course it's now day 247 of Americans
abandoned in Afghanistan but again don't
expect Circle back gen socket ever
correct the record last year's sake also
repeatedly lied about the
administration's so-called progress at
our Southern border 2021 ends up like
the worst single worst year of illegal
immigration in history with more
apprehensions than ever before including
a record number of unaccompanied
children can you really call that
progress Jen and of course Jen's uh
don't forget about Biden's overcrowded
cages for kids remember those cages you
put the kids in and overcrowded in the
middle of a pandemic uh and don't forget
the preferential treat treatment that
Joe Biden is giving illegal immigrants
no covet tests no vaccine mandates
jensaki said uh because they're not
going to be here very long here means in
that exact same spot because they
usually would fly them all around the
country 2 A.M 3 A.M 4 a.m flights of
illegal immigrants flown into obscure
airports but according to gen that's not
the middle of the night 2 A.M 4 a.m is
not the middle of the night they are
called early morning flights in msdnc
gen sake land and remember saki also
lied when she blamed Putin for the rise
in gas prices we proved that to be a lie
last week again she lied when she said
inflation was transitory and temporary
we proved that to be a lie last week she
even lied about the price of hot dogs
and get this jensakio once actually
accused Republicans of supporting the
defund the police movement not true now
sadly these lies are just the tip of the
iceberg but as always we'll let you
decide
you may have noticed this week that your
gas prices have gone up I want to talk
to you a little bit about why a lot of
it has to do with Vladimir Putin
broadly known and widely known Peter
that there was a broad range of Russian
disinformation back in 2020. why is the
administration flying thousands of
migrants from the border to Florida and
New York in the middle of the night
well I'm not sure that it's in the
middle of the night as individuals come
across the border and they are both
assessed for whether they have any
symptoms if they have symptoms they are
the intention is for them to be
quarantined that is our process they're
not intending to stay here for a lengthy
period of time now ultimately gen sake
is the perfect representation of this
White House dishonest classless
mean-spirited with their religious
cult-like belief and far left policies
that hurt the country now the biggest
lie from this White House is hiding
Right In Plain Sight Joe Biden your
president is not up to the job of being
president he is so obviously struggling
cognitively but the administration
they're pretending like all is well well
all is not well and today a White House
staffer dressed up a one who got this
job as an as the Easter Bunny blocking
the president from answering questions
about foreign policy things that
actually matter no you can't don't let
Joe talk off the top of his head he
can't handle it why is the Easter Bunny
interrupting the president of the United
States and blocking him from answering
questions and at one point during the
very same event well first lady Jill
Biden she was forced to remind Joey to
wave wave Joe wave take a look
welcome to the South lawn thank you and
happy happy Easter
all right apparently
thank you
wave Joe she also had to remind her
husband where to sit take a look
she's suddenly just [ __ ] don't worry
she's a teacher I'm the teacher you know
I'm the teacher
the first lady also helped the president
read a children's book He needed help
take a look
okay so I'm going to quickly read
brown bear brown bear so you're all not
soaking wet and they're not going to let
me read it all
I'll let you here you can start us off
can you oh here can I agree backwards
go ahead brown bear brown bear what do
you see
I see a bird looking at me now you got
it okay yellow duck yellow duck what do
you see I see a blue horse looking at me
Blue Horse hold on
All Right In fairness it's nice they're
reading to Children okay I can deal with
all of that but does anyone really
believe that Joe Biden is capable of
handling the rigors of what is
definitely the hardest job on Earth
remember last week very confused looking
Biden attempted to shake hands after his
speech watch she's shaking hands
with nobody
where oh and he leaves his hand there
for several seconds looks around with
his hand out you know where is everybody
take a look for yourself
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I I don't know what to say does anyone
around Joe Biden this is a serious
question
that they love him enough to do the
right thing
and tell them Joe for your own personal
good and the good of the country you
need to consider retiring immediately
anybody care about them because
apparently even the president's Hometown
paper that would be the Washington Post
they seemingly want him gone a little
embarrassing today kind of a huge insult
to the White House as the Washington
Post published this article the top 10
Democratic presidential candidates for
2024 ranked now they do have Joey at
number one he's intent on if if he's
intent on running for reelection at
number two it's not Kamala Harris nope
there it is transportation
Transportation secretary small town
mayor South Bend Pete Buda judge with
that wealth of experience that he has
and his advice and everyone buy a an
electric car and get used to high gas
prices because uh unless we have energy
independence from clean new energy well
never gonna stop paying the high prices
for gasoline number three vice president
it Kamala Harris God help us the
administration is in a free fall and now
even the media mob is looking to jump
ship hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else